bonjour bonsoir plutôt bonsoir à tous
moi je suis ravi d'être ici qui ravit
surtout parler d'un sujet qui me
passionne moi c'est à dire l'histoire
des religions et on veut en nous allons
essayer ensemble d'aborder le sujet des
enjeux de la globalisation des religions
de la place de deux de la critique du
religieux et aussi de la légitimité ou
pas la légitimité du blasphème et c'est
un sujet qui est qui est vraiment irréel
dans le sens où on a en france encore
enfin en france en europe sept pays qui
ont inscrit le principe de blasphème
dans l'eure dans leur code pénal donc
c'est un vrai sujet mais c'est un sujet
mais c'est en train de bouger
heureusement moi de mon côté je co quand
je travaille se re sur mes bouquins ou
sur mes recherches j'ai bien sûr un
esprit critique
mais de l'autre côté je suis à la limite
du blasphème le blasphème c'est l'injure
faite à la divinité le dernier en france
qui a payé le prix fort le chevet de la
salle au xviiie siècle
il a terminé quand même les os brisés
brûlé vivant avec un livre de voltaire
cloué sur la poitrine
donc c'est quand même un sujet qui peut
devenir très sérieux dans certaines
circonstances le camp je travaille sur
ces sujets j'essaye d'être indépendant
j'essaie de porter un regard neuf et
donc par exemple mon travail sur le jëf
une biographie il ya que vous allez y en
a plus j'ai fait une biographie non
autorisée de jésus c'est à dire que
j'ai fait abstraction de tous les textes
qui sont les textes retenus tous les
textes officiels
tous les textes dit inspiré et je ne me
suis concentré que sur des textes qui
étaient mis de côté qui étaient cachés
les certes les fameuses apps écrit entre
autres donc 70 textes et donc j'ai
raconté j'ai travaillé sur une vie de
jésus à partir de l'avis de courant
minoritaire qui était à travers l'
empire romain chrétien qui passait le
même message à la fin mais qui raconter
une histoire différente mais cc du
blasphème sur les conditions de le
verser du blasphème
j'ai fait une biographie aussi de me
donne aux is par exemple à moïse
j'aurais très bien pu me fatiguer
prendre l'exode dans la bible et puis
voilà tout est raconté
il suffisait de travailler dessus pas du
tout j'ai fait comme si je n'avais pas
l'exode
j'ai voulu regarder avec un autre regard
c'est ça l'esprit critique c'est
regarder autrement et je me suis appuyée
que sur les légendes
éthiopienne sur moïse et sur les récits
grecque est donc là j'ai un autre
personnage une autre vision qui m'a
enrichi dans ma compréhension de la
vision officielle
donc ce sont des sujets intéressants
marie-madeleine par exemple il ya mille
choses à dire sur marie madeleine mais
quand je travaille sur ce sujet là je me
suis intéressée qu'à l'aspect féministes
du personnage donc plutôt sur ce qu'elle
incarne dans le futur voilà donc c'est
une c'est une façon de regarder d'esprit
critique c'est une façon regarder il
faut des réalités la grande majorité des
personnes qui sont qui se définissent à
partir d'une religion 84% de l'humanité
se définit à partir d'une religion bien
la grande majorité de ces personnes
considèrent que leur religion à la
vérité avec un grand v
c'est difficile il ya 4000 religion un
seul monde 4000 religion la question ce
n'est pas la question de la vérité
évidemment c'est la question du style de
vie mais ça ne peut pas être la question
de la vérité
pour une raison encore plus inquiétante
c'est que 4000 religion aucune n'est
original il n'a pas il n'existe pas de
religion qu'ils soient nés ex nihilo de
rien qui serait arrivé comme ça comme
athéna kiné de l'intelligence de zeus et
lan et très adulte casqués armés
aucune religion donnée comme ça toutes
les religions sont le résultat d'emprunt
c'est à dire que l ont pris des mythes
des récits d'autres religions et elle se
les sont pourquoi pas
elle se les sont appropriés et souvent
les ont déformé
c'est l'arrivée des anges par exemple
dans la pensée biblique est totalement
contradictoire avec la pensée
monothéistes une pensée monothéistes
c'est que le pouvoir universel n'est
qu'à une seule personne un de ces
personnes une seule divinité une seule
entité
y'a pas d'assistant ya pas de délégation
de pouvoir donc les anges dans le
monothéisme y en a pas seulement comme
les juifs ont été déportés à babylone en
586 avant jésus-christ ben ils ceux ci
ont été influencés par ce n'est pas
parce qu'il voyait quand ils sont
revenus ils ont été libérés une
cinquantaine d'années après ils sont
venus avec les génies et les qui
protégeait les maisons des babyloniens
donc ils ont introduit les anges qui
l'ont pris chez les mésopotamiens et les
ont introduits chez eux même façon moïse
tout le récit mosaïque et le récit du
dieu marzouk
c'est pas un récit original il suffit de
lire l'histoire de marduk et on le
comprend
abraham quand il est repris dans le
coran milan après que son récit était
écrit dans genesis
il le transforme un petit peu mais c'est
un emprunt c'est pas une réalité il ya
un voyage dans le temps donc c'est un
emprunt à ce qui s'est passé
donc le le jésus personnage le plus cité
dans le coran
27 fois alors que le prophète main mais
je crois qu'il essayait 3,4 donc ça
c'est très intéressant aussi c'est un
emprunt donc il n'ya pas de religion
original c'est à dire aucune ne peut
revendiquer une sorte de vérité absolue
qui jaillirait comme ça du néant
donc en réalité elles naissent de
blasphème elles naissent de déformation
d'autres religions donc ça je pense que
c'est un sujet que c'est vraiment une
important pour comprendre pourquoi ce
n'est pas possible de perpétuer le
blasphème la question qu'on peut se
poser quand même c'est comment tout a
commencé
parce qu'en fin de compte vous verrez
que c'est assez simple la notion de
blasphème
enfin en tout cas la légitimité qu'on
peut lui prêter il ya 15000 en jeu m'a
jamais revenir la cueillette il ya
quinze mille ans 1
les populations qui étaient toujours en
déplacement puisque c'étaient des
cueilleurs chasseurs a toujours en
déplacement toujours en mouvement etc
ils ont décidé en partie de commencer à
se sédentariser
maintenant cette sédentarisation
on n'en connaît pas la cause c'est pas
une cause alimentaire on peut imaginer
peut-être que le rapport à la mort a
changé parce qu'il y aura des tombes
différentes aussi à ce moment là on peut
penser que le rapport à la mort
peut-être la perception que la mort
était réellement inéluctable en tout cas
il ya un changement de rapport avec les
défunts je ne dis pas que c'est la
raison je dis que ça pourrait être une
des raisons parce qu'on est là bas de
l'autre et donc ils commencent à
sédentariser une partie va opter pour le
nomadisme pastorale c'est à dire le
nomadisme fermé donc ils vont nomadiser
selon les saisons sur un territoire
toujours le même et puis d'autres ils
vont choisir l'économie agricole et ils
vont rester sur un territoire sans
bouger qu'est ce qui se passe le
territoire qui était avant un lieu de
passage main devient en fin de compte un
terrain territoire nourricier
si les nourricier il est sacralisé et la
question va se poser de qui a accès au
territoire à partir de ce moment là on a
construit une échelle on s'est construit
une échelle des différences pour définir
ce qu'ils ont ou pas accès au territoire
les relations endogamique des relations
les rapports sexuels et c'est à
l'intérieur du groupe font que on à
préciser les caractéristiques physiques
des uns et du coup on a créé une des
caractères des caractéristiques des
données physiques qui correspondent aux
territoires
ce n'est pas une ethnie qui est entré
sur un territoire c'est le territoire
qui a fabriqué les tenues ça c'est un
cétacé important ensuite
il va y avoir là la différenciation de
rôle entre le féminin et masculin ça
date de ce moment là on le sait parce
que quand on étudie les tribus qui
vivent encore à la période de la
cueillette en tout cas sur le même le
rythme de vie
il n'y a pas de différenciation entre le
féminin masculin ni dans les les
objectifs dans le travail dans les
responsabilités ni dans les déplacements
et ses appels et des enfants donc et
puis le cette sédentarisation et surtout
la sacralité du territoire elle a
inventé l'étranger
étrange étrange et n'oublions pas que
dans étrangers les racines que ce soit
les textes anciens ou même latin ça veut
dire des monts ça veut dire hostilités
ça veut dire ennemis ça veut dire
victime sacrificielle un bouc émissaire
donc on est on est vraiment une
construction de l'étranger dans le sens
celui qui n'est pas moi donc on entre
avec la sacralité du territoire on va
entrer dans une logique de ressemblance
c'est à dire que la ressemblance va
rassurer la ressemblance va renforcer la
société et en fin de compte la
ressemblance va être le ferment de la
société toute divergence de la
ressemblance de la norme et donc une
atteinte au peuple est une atteinte au
territoire
on est dans le blasphème
c'est une atteinte
à la divinité parce qu on est dans un
modèle qui est un peuple un territoire
une divinité protectrice comme ça les
moutons étaient bien gardés c'était
chacun sait soir qu'est ce qui s'est
passé globalisation de l'économie libre
circulation des idées des placement
accéléré des personnes c'est vrai
désacralisation des territoires
déterritorialisation des cultures c'est
à dire les cultures qui s'était
construite à partir d'un territoire et
est souvent d'une géographie les
cultures voyage maintenant et peuvent
être plusieurs des centaines à cohabiter
sur un territoire qui est partagé on
n'est plus du tout dans la logique de la
ressemblance
on est dans la logique de la différence
est donc dans cette société là où les
différences font le ciment de la société
ben il ya la place pour la critique mais
ya pas de place pour le blasphème
parce que nous ne sommes plus dans le
culte de la ressemblance
alors ce qui se passe maintenant ce
qu'on ressent parce que il ya beaucoup
de tension sur tous ces sujets là et
surtout sur le sujet des religions on
sent beaucoup exagéré parce que les
religions contre moins ce qu'on pense
sont des organisations intelligente et
que dans leur construction
je l étais des avancées sociales
les avancées sociales dans leur période
donc elles ne sont pas archaïque c'est
les pratiques qui sont archaïques
c'est les interprétations qui sont
archaïques donc le résultat de cette
modification d'identité des personnes
puisque nous passons d'une identité
construction à la ressemblance à une
identité collective construite sur les
les différences
j'ai perdu le fil maintenant oui à
partir de ce moment là on a on assiste à
un bouleversement de sociétal un
bouleversement culturel de la société
on est moi j'appelle au regret qu'une
crise grecque antique donc une crise
c'est à dire peut-être le le cheminement
sur lent mais certain vers une situation
le paroxysme une situation à laquelle il
coordonne une réponse et un choix de
société on est en train d'arriver
lentement à cette situation là ce que je
dirai juste pour conclure c'est que ces
crises dont on parle c'est n'est pas une
menace
cette crise et c'est une évolution c'est
une ouvre des possibilités
donc c'est pas un combat contre les
religions à aucun moment parce que les
religions sont assez grandes
elles vont s'adapter comme se sont
toujours adaptés
je pense que les systèmes de pensée
religieux sont tout à fait capables de
s'organiser autour de croyance inclusive
et peut-être que ce sera le moment où on
y arrivera et donc ce bouleversement
dont je parle
cette crise hills en fin de compte c'est
simplement une crise de croissance
éthique et pas du tout une menace c'est
tout
[Applaudissements]